Welcome back, Master.
Master.
Lady.
It's night time.
I don't think we should hike at night, though.
Jolly Rammer, it's your birthday!
Please don't sing if your throat is sore.
Thank you, Mintoa Whisper, for making this year so unforgettable.
I wrote that as uncomfortable.
Thanks, everybody, for making this year so uncomfortable.
Jolly Rammer, enjoy!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Jolly Rammer.
Is that unforgettable, not un...
The star watching Mint's streams and she's already convinced me to play DMZ 5.
Thanks, Nate!
Even though I know nothing about the series.
Wait, why are you starting at 5?
Oh my gosh.
Is this Ragebite?
I love this game.
One of my favorites.
I've never played this game before.
Wait, it's starting to get darker and darker.
MGS moment.
True!
Will you guys...
Will you guys, in like 10 minutes, tell me to take my medicine?
Can I interest you guys with being my alarms?
My tea is still too hot.
Okay.
Thank you in like 10, 15 minutes.
I gotta take my medicine.
Thanks for all the 9 months!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
You guys, I had a funny dream last night.
Actually, no.
That's a lie.
It wasn't last night.
It was the night before last and I forgot to tell you guys.
I had a dream that I hosted a...
This is gonna sound so silly.
I hosted a ghost tour.
Even though I'm a ghost.
I hosted a ghost tour at some like mansion.
That I... Oh my gosh!
Chat is green.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome back and welcome!
Thank you.
You can host and spook.
True.
But, I hosted a ghost tour and then I posted about it on Twitter.
I was just like...
I was like, I wonder how many people are gonna come to my ghost tour.
And then I... The day happens and I was just like...
Wow!
There's a lot more people than I expected.
And...
And I...
I was like, the mansion is not that big.
And so, me and my mom, I think it was.
Sorry, the details are a little fuzzy because it was the other day that I dreamt this.
We were like, okay, let's figure out how to split people.
How many... How many...
How many...
Like, people per group.
And everybody will travel as a group and I'll like, hop between groups.
So I can say hi to everybody.
And...
We were discussing it and everybody who came for the tour all just went inside the mansion.
And just started the tour anyway.
And I was like...
After I finished figuring out all the math, which took me an exceptionally long time.
Because literally everybody was gone.
And then I also left too.
Like, I think I had to leave the premises to consult someone else.
To figure out how to divide these groups.
Because I remember having to take like an Uber back to...
Which I'm banned from Uber.
I say Uber, I don't use Uber because I'm banned from Uber.
But...
It's just easier to say.
I remember my Uber driver being like...
That mansion is haunted.
I was like, I know, I know.
And...
I don't know why I'm banned from Uber, I don't know.
I didn't do anything, they just banned me one day.
I probably haunted too much or something, I don't know.
Mighty Wub, happy early birthday!
Anyway...
I get back to the mansion and everybody's gone.
And I was just like, oh my gosh.
And so I was like, okay, I'll go in.
And it's not that, it's a mansion.
But it's not like the biggest mansion in the world.
And there were so many people.
I'll surely be able to run into somebody quickly.
And I go in and nobody's there.
And I'm like going through every room and I'm like...
Where is everybody?
And I go into the basement.
And...
I go into the basement.
I go into one room.
The basement has so many rooms, it's like a very liminal space.
Feels very backrooms-ish.
And I open up a door and I see three people in the room.
Two are VTubers.
One is a VTuber that I recognize.
And one is a VTuber I think I made up in my head.
And then the third is a celebrity.
The VTuber I recognize is Chiyo Champi.
I love her.
Sorry, that was my controller disconnecting.
I watch her streams all the time.
And...
No, it wasn't Ryan Gosling!
You'll never...
It wasn't Ryan.
It was...
It was Eminem.
And like, Chiyo and the other VTuber are like face in the corner for some reason.
Like Blair Witch Project style.
But Eminem is conscious.
And he follows...
I was like, oh hey Eminem!
And he follows me out of the room like uncomfortably close.
And I was like, Eminem, can I help you?
He was like, Mint!
You haven't complimented how I look today!
Do I look good today?
And I was like...
I was like, what do you mean Eminem?
And he was like, I wore this Final Fantasy shirt for you!
That's exactly what Eminem would say.
Yeah, exactly.
I was like, oh yeah!
Looking sharp, Eminem!
And that was my dream.
Are you sure it was the real Slim Shady?
Maybe.
It could have been just...
I called him Eminem first, so...
Sorry I turned up late.
Is she describing a dream?
No, this happened in real life.
No, I'm just kidding.
Yeah, it was a dream.
So Eminem, I like your Final Fantasy T-shirt.
I didn't think that he wanted a compliment though.
Eminem's a little clingy maybe.
Set back to reality.
I'm not the father, sorry.
I'd want a copy of this dream in DVD format, please.
It's crazy because it's one of those types of dreams that I can still see visually in my head.
Right now.
Minto didn't have anyone to take on her ghost tour.
Eminem, now this looks like a job for me.
It feels like one of those Scooby Doo collaboration episodes.
Eminem and Minto collab win.
I feel I'm a little more congested today.
I'm sorry guys, that's why I'm waiting to take my medicine.
But, we're gonna play a short hike.
I don't wanna go hiking actually.
I wanna hike in the video game.
I don't wanna actually do any work.
I want to be able to chill and just relax.
You know, maybe this is a good way to... If you had a busy week, maybe we can...
Hot dog, that's right.
We can relax with Minto.
What's this game about?
I have no idea.
Hey Minky, today's my birthday.
I was wondering if you could wish me a happy birthday, please.
You don't have to be bald for it.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, blonde Uchiha.
Happy birthday, memorable man.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted memberships.
Thank you, I appreciate it so much.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah, let's just get into it.
Start the game.
I'll never get tired of this view.
I like the view.
You're my best view.
Claire.
You're gonna have a great time here this summer.
Oh, it's summer?
I did have a busy week and almost became an IRL ghost driving home in the snow yesterday.
Please don't become an IRL ghost.
Take your medicine, Minto.
Has it been 10 minutes?
Oh, I think it has.
Meds time!
I think.
Time for meds, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you.
I took 10 minutes describing my dream?
Time flies when you're yapping, it's true.
Beep beep 10 minutes.
Beep beep beep beep beep.
I like how the animal crossing is talking.
It'll be good to get away from the city.
Hold on.
5 more minutes.
It's still not cool enough.
Sun!
Welcome to Mambushu.
Thank you.
It's one of my favorite games, really.
Take a break from everything else going on.
Are you still awake?
Maybe.
Hold on a little longer.
We're almost at the ferry.
The ferry.
A humble original...
Oh, these are credits.
Is that me?
Just a little bird.
I built this.
Shiny.
I think it's a little loud.
Window from 10 minutes in the future.
Don't take the med...
No!
I need to!
I can jump.
What else can I do?
Shell.
This is my inventory.
I have a cell phone.
I love that short video.
Thank you!
Welcome back to Mambushu.
Thank you.
What's this?
This looks like something I can grab.
Let's set myself on fire.
Oh.
Hey, how's it going?
I haven't seen you all day.
You been busy?
Well, kinda.
Well, not really.
I've been waiting around for a call.
Shut up.
Welcome to Mambushu.
Thank you.
Balthazar.
Thanks for the gift.
Well, there's your problem.
There's no reception out here.
What?
Nani?
Yeah, I mean, pretty much no reception.
You might be able to...
You might be able to get some at Hawk Peak.
Funky nighty.
Thanks for the...
Oh, yeah, I guess.
Don't say it.
I'm not!
I'm not saying it!
God.
I wish we could redo 2024.
I wish we could redo...
I wanna go back...
I wanna time machine and go back in time.
Maliceius?
I hope I said that right.
Welcome to Mambushu.
That's pretty far, isn't it?
It's not that far.
We've all made the trek before.
I figured you would've gone already.
Oh, yeah.
I've been meaning to go.
But...
I just haven't gotten around to it yet.
Well, today is as good a day as any.
Just take White Beach Trail and head north at the fork.
Then follow the signs for Hawk Peak.
Thank God they don't say two in front of it.
I'm so scared!
Chuggie!
Welcome to Mambushu.
It's been a good nine months.
Thank you!
Reese, thanks for the Super Chat.
Joshua, welcome back.
This game is making my computer lag.
No problem.
Is this the trail?
White Coast Trail.
Ranger's Cabin.
That doesn't seem very safe.
I reckon that seems a little dangerous.
Seems a little dangerous.
Who are you?
Mysterious traveler?
Claire!
Did you know?
You can hold A while running to glide through the air?
Of course!
Everyone knows that.
Why do you ask?
I don't know.
I just had a feeling you might want to know.
Pregante joke here.
Okay.
What do I do over here?
There is a shiny up here.
I got a coin.
I'm rich.
In friendship.
We can fly so much.
See?
Look at these plants.
I want to do something with them.
What?
Why?
I want to.
Yeah, but why?
It's a secret.
Okay.
I'll keep an eye out.
Keep both eyes out, please.
God, these kids are so pushy.
A stick.
I got one stick.
I'm gonna beat this kid up with it.
So what's the deal with the shells?
It's none of your business.
Except for the business of you getting me 15 of them.
Do it yourself!
Lazy ass kid.
Look, there is literally one right here.
Is that one?
No.
Meds time.
Thank you.
I'm worried.
I choked on this pill yesterday.
So I'm scared.
I'm not good at taking pills.
So I have to like kind of...
I have to like...
Can you guys give me encouragement?
It makes me scared because I choked yesterday.
Ahem.
I did it!
It started to taste so bad.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Oh gosh, with the mouse.
Okay, I can't...
Had my cane for a couple of years.
Finally decided to name it.
It has a cool blue handle so I named it my cool cane.
Cool!
Wait, someone...
Kyoki!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Okay, I'm not gonna move my mouse anymore.
Okay, I'm gonna put it here just in case I need to scroll up on chat.
But I'm not gonna...
Senjou, welcome to membership.
Yippee!
I took my medicine!
Okay, what's this?
Ranger's cabin.
White coaster L.
But what is this?
I'm bigger than the door.
Who lives here?
Sick.
Money?
Coin and shell.
Can we fish?
Is this like Animal Crossing?
Hawk Peak Trail, White Coast Trail, Sid Beach Visitor Center.
Look!
It is like Animal Crossing!
Wait, what's that up there?
Oh my gosh, treasure?
Who are you?
Hey Claire!
How's the day treating ya?
Well, I'm just getting out of the house now.
It's one of those kinds of days.
Yeah, I've been kind of caught up in my head all morning.
Would you say you feel lost and directionless?
Maybe.
Well, I've got just the thing for you.
Oh no, it's an MLM.
Take this.
Oh, a compass!
To use it, press Y to open your inventory.
Then select it from the items bin.
Oh, thanks.
This should come in handy.
Happy hiking!
Hiking!
Okay, how do we...
Get up...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
And then...
Big money.
I usually just put it under my tongue, that way I don't actually have to taste it.
But how do you swallow it?
How do you swallow it then if you...
If you don't.
Your Ayami model is really beautiful.
Thank you!
Ayami-mama did such an amazing job, yeah?
Yeah.
Down here.
Oh, froggy.
Hey dude, what's happening?
Oh, you know.
Just jamming out on the beach.
Building sandcastles and whatnot.
Are we to disappear?
No!
You guys are not my hallucinations, right?
You're not my delusions.
I mean, I know I'm delusional.
But you're not my delusions, right?
Sounds like a good time.
Isn't it a little big for that?
You can get smaller ones.
Ones made for sandcastles.
What?
Sounds fake.
But if you can show me one, I'd be glad to trade.
Is it in this box?
That would be really mighty convenient.
Nope.
What?
There's a rock climbing?
This place is crazy.
Is this like a summer camp or something?
Why can't I fish with my beak?
I'm a bird.
I wish I could be Minky's disembodied schizo voice.
No, you guys are real.
Right?
What if you guys all stopped using the chat at once?
It wouldn't do that.
Just to prove a point.
Hey.
Hey there.
What are you up to today?
I'm hiking up to hawk...
Hawk Peak.
Two.
Period.
Hawk Peak.
That's a tough hike.
Marley, thanks for 7 months.
You know, you'll need to learn to rock climb to make it to the top.
Why not join our rock climbing club?
Is it just the two of you?
Hey.
The Rock Climbers Association has hundreds of members spanning over 35 countries worldwide.
Hundreds of members growing and refining the art of rock climbing.
Pushing the...
I can't keep it up.
Pushing the craft to its absolute limit and beyond.
Best way to take pills.
Put in your mouth with water and drink with your head looking down.
Oh, it doesn't help me though.
I tried.
I meant, if it's just the two of you.
Like, here?
What of it?
Listen, kid.
Climbing ain't for the weak of heart.
This guy sucks.
Most people don't have what it takes.
Your actions have consequences.
It's not really that bad.
So anyway.
You want to join the climbers club?
Sure.
I like the mirage dance.
Thank you.
For real, you have to believe me.
Belive me.
We've got our third member.
Not third.
Just another drop in the hundreds.
Worldwide.
Alright, alright.
Anyway.
So first things first.
You got a golden feather?
Oh, not yet.
You can't climb without one.
But you can buy them at the visitor center.
Why didn't you bring that up first?
I have to pay to join, but not really?
They should be pretty cheap.
Come back when you've bought one.
Okay.
Who are you?
I've heard some rumors.
Do you like rumors?
I dabble.
Okay, hear me out.
Chim just bought a metal detector.
He was running around yesterday, looking for stuff on the island.
It was going nuts.
Seems like there's stuff buried all over the island.
What kind of stuff?
I don't know.
Metal stuff?
Metal gears, perhaps?
Treasure.
Shall we treasure hunt today?
This game is so cute.
I think we're gonna have to water these.
That's my suspicion.
Oops, I just...
I fell off, truly.
Let's see.
I wanna go back because I wanna go up.
I can go up here, right?
Wait, can I go up here?
Okay, good.
More money.
He says cheap, but...
I don't trust him.
We don't know what the currency is like in this universe.
Easy, easy.
Lots of money.
Let's go back around again.
How big is this island?
How am I...
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
It's money.
Select to toggle on or off.
Select.
Show.
Okay, it's in the corner.
Oh.
Oh!
We're trespassing.
Excuse me, do you have the time?
What's the conversion of Haiku coins to USD?
I don't know.
We don't know what the economy is like here.
Yeah, let me check.
See, normally I would know the time.
I just lost my watch.
Oh, sorry.
Video games made me believe I would stumble upon many boxes with useful items or money in them.
In reality, most boxes I find have nothing good in them.
Video games made me think boxes held men.
It was very expensive.
And priceless when you consider the sentimental value.
He's trauma-dumping.
I think the game is set in Canada, so sadly the money isn't worth much.
I see.
If you find it, can you bring it back to me?
Sure.
Please don't sell it on the internet or whatever.
It's very valuable to me.
No, don't worry.
I'll bring it right back.
Okay, thanks.
It's probably right in here.
Stupid guy doesn't know how to dig.
Just use your hands.
He's like, I'm a goat.
Why would we buy a golden feather?
No way.
It's just within...
If only I knew how to rock climb.
Oh my god, it's just within my reach.
Hold on.
I'm smart.
Wait, hello?
Come on.
Why is the pathway so steep?
I did it.
I didn't even need to pay for it.
Minto, don't take your meds.
Too late.
What the?
What was that?
I dropped a feather.
I'm molting.
Did you see that?
I climbed.
Hawk Peak Trail.
Notice.
Hawk Peak Trail is a strenuous hike.
I thought this was supposed to be a cozy time.
You might need golden feathers to complete it.
Golden feathers are for sale at the visitor center.
What?
Feathers?
What do you mean by that?
This place is humongous.
Humongous among us.
I feel like I'm about to see a dead body in here, you know?
Gold feather stamina.
I see.
It's a toy shovel.
No, no, don't use my golden feather.
Don't use it willy nilly.
Now we go back to Frogport.
I can't believe I'm 30 minutes late.
I forgive you, Eggman.
Just goes to show I'm a little under the weather.
No, just like me.
I was so stopped up I didn't even smell...
There's gonna be a marathon race at Meteor Lake today.
The competition this year is fierce.
Okay.
I might be a little lost.
Visitor center, Hoth Beach.
Sid Beach, okay.
So we are on the right path.
Oh wait, I know.
Kind of.
Down here is where the rock climbing is.
Somewhere.
There, yeah.
But hold on, before we do that...
Check out this shovel I found.
Golden feather recharges.
Might be a little more your size.
Well that's perfect.
Let's trade.
When you want to use my shovel, press Y to open your inventory and equip it.
Keep it fresh.
Shovel.
Press B to equip.
Alright, nice.
Up there.
Okay.
Wait.
Let's go around.
This way.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Were there other places to dig?
I can't remember.
Was there anything else back this way?
Maybe not, huh?
Oh, nope.
One by the golden feather.
Okay.
This game is so cute.
Oh my god!
He is building a whole civilization!
We've given him so much power!
Oh my gosh!
All it took was a little...
All he needed was a better shovel!
He's unstoppable!
I didn't get much sleep last night, you guys.
Howdy.
How can I help you?
I heard you sell golden feathers here.
We do.
You can buy 40 coins!
I'm just a child.
What else do you sell?
We also sell provincial park merchandise.
We're kind of low on stock.
But that's good, actually.
It's been a busy season.
Provincial parks must be trending or something.
It's possible.
Anyway, we only have one hat left.
It costs 100 coins!
I'll pass.
Okay.
Yikes.
Oh, there was one right around here, right?
Oh gosh.
Hello?
There we go.
More money.
That was not your...
That was not your watch, I'm sorry!
Mysterious cave?
Nevermind.
100 coins.
What does he think I'm made of?
Absolute scam.
Who are you?
That's what I said!
I was planning on hiking to... period.
Hawk Peak, period.
But the path suddenly got really steep.
Do you think it's climbable?
Well, it would be if I had a golden feather.
Apparently they sell them at the visitor center.
Oh,
oh, hello?
Am I stupid?
Oh, there we go.
Apparently I am.
Hi.
Hi!
Are you okay?
Not really.
I'm supposed to run a marathon race today.
But I've lost my lucky headband.
I've worn it to every race I've ever run.
I don't know if I could race without it.
Where'd you lose it?
Somewhere in the Blackwood Forest.
I think.
I could take a look for you.
Really?
You'd do that for me?
Sure.
It's a red headband.
I could give you a reward.
I could give you a pair of running shoes.
Don't you need those yourself?
Well, I just got sponsored by the shoe company.
They gave me like ten pairs.
Wow!
Yippee, no more sickness.
You're... you?
You're not sick anymore?
I like Minto because of the way that she is.
How am I?
Congrats.
Thanks.
But let me know if you see a red headband.
Okay.
It's this way, right?
Blackwood Trail.
Okay.
So maybe we go this way and then go up?
Oh?
Money, money, money, money, money.
The music is so nice.
This guy is wearing... I think this guy stole the headband.
Wait, wait, wait.
Come back you thief!
Weird question, but where did you get that headband?
I don't know.
I had it for ages.
Why?
I was just talking to this rabbit.
She said she lost her headband somewhere in the forest.
Wait, you mean Sue?
Maybe?
I didn't get her name.
She was really worried about it though.
You're pretty... good.
She said it was lucky and she needs it to race.
I'm supposed to race her later today.
Oh my gosh, it's the tortoise and the hare.
She's so talented.
I've been really looking forward to it.
I think this guy is a liar.
What if I gave you mine?
I'm pretty sure it's the same kind.
No, this guy is a nice guy.
It's Raphael.
He's a mutant turtle.
Everybody loves Amito.
She's a terrific maid.
Thank you.
Maybe she wouldn't notice.
But then it wouldn't be lucky.
I don't know.
Just take it.
See if she wants it.
Ew, I don't want to take someone else's nasty sweaty headband.
That sounds horrible.
Unless... they're a cute girl.
Then... I'll consider it.
Five minute alarm.
Is that for the... for my medicine?
I think the notice are backed up a little bit.
Thank you!
Oh wait, I think I went to the wrong one.
I tried to fly to that one instead.
I went the wrong way.
I'm trapped.
Girl sweat.
Look at him, he's doing all his rounds.
Oh, money, money, money.
Little coin.
I want the hat.
Oh, I have enough for the hat.
I might be rich.
Meteor Lake.
Overlook.
Hawk Peak Trail.
Blackwood Trail.
Would you take Snake's headband?
Would you sniff it?
It would smell so bad, most likely.
It would probably smell the worst.
Oh my god, they're running.
Me too!
Oh my god, we're all running.
Look how fast I am!
I am speed!
Everybody...
Watch out, eat my dust!
I'm the best one to ever do it!
You guys don't... You don't stand a chance against me.
Look, I can wait here.
I don't even know what the pathway is.
I wish I were a bird.
I hate leg days.
Wait, can he push me?
Dang it, I thought he was going to push me to victory.
Good morning.
Good morning!
This place is a little overwhelming with how much I can go.
More money.
How's it going?
Good.
The fish are biting today.
Cool, cool.
So, uh, is fishing hard?
Nope.
It's easy.
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon!
Your name is cut off.
Does it show me your kittens?
Thanks for the five kittens!
I could show you... Oh!
He's going to show you the kitties.
Kitties.
Yeah.
Oh, he's showing me.
Okay, I'll lend you my spare rod.
Yay!
Okay, we fish now.
Cast your line.
Casting your line is pretty easy.
Just press B.
Aggressive.
Oh, kittens.
So...
What do I do now?
Yo, wait.
Oh.
Okay.
Uh, am I doing this right?
Maybe.
Maybe I should cast it again.
You know, find a better spot.
This spot is good.
I saw some fish around here earlier.
That's a good sign.
Sometimes, you just gotta wait.
Patience is key.
Not my strong suit.
It's so quiet.
Look alive!
A fish is nibbling!
Should I pull it out?
Not yet.
You gotta wait for it to bite.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, now!
Press B!
Oh, what do I...
Oh, pull back and tap B!
Pull back?
Interesting technique.
That's...
That's scripted, right?
Marie!
Oh my gosh!
Thanks for the raid!
Hello!
Hello, hello.
Bring it back!
Thanks for the five gifted!
That's alright.
Just give it another shot.
And remember, once you hook the fish...
Pull back and tap B.
Wait, I did pull back!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, sorry I fell in the water.
It's pretty embarrassing.
Thanks for the gift, dude!
Alvin Kapo!
Thank you!
I can't see it too.
Rubber, rubber.
Thank you, thank you guys!
So do I go back on the...
I don't know.
I'll try.
Not at all.
You got spirit.
Okay, alright, alright.
Oh, wait!
I wanna do it again!
Oops, sorry.
I scared away that fish.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Albino Northern Pike!
Yeah, baby!
How many seashells?
Okay, we only got seven.
This guy is so chill.
I'm so stoked to eat breakfast.
Oh, but it's already the afternoon.
Tomorrow's breakfast.
It's the best meal of the day.
Okay, dude.
Not gonna lie, I agree with that.
I think breakfast food is some of the best food.
It's so good.
Like...
Getting like a waffle...
Hash browns...
Bacon...
Oh, it's so good.
It's so good.
Maybe I'll have breakfast for dinner today.
This guy is a freak.
Go into the water.
Nice.
Go into the fire.
Wake up log.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh, I should introduce myself.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Mint Phantom.
I'm a ghost maid.
I'm a little sick, so sorry if you hear me.
Like a coughing baby.
Oh my god.
I didn't know that I could go out here.
I thought I was gonna get invisible wall, but no.
Minecraft.
Can I take this?
Nice.
Fast travel.
Oh, that's nice.
So...
Maybe that area I found before actually was...
was...
a cave that I could explore.
It's kind of spooky over here though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Why is this mine abandoned?
Why was it sealed up?
Am I gonna die?
I'm gonna fish.
Wait.
Why?
Equip.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, sorry.
There we go.
I'm scared of the thunder lightning.
We just have to wait.
Hi, dog.
Mr. Cooper Black.
I thought we had a fish for sure.
What?
Yeah, baby!
What did I get?
A tiny brook trout.
So small.
See, like this looks like we can break it.
No, I guess not.
Should I be over here?
Did it suddenly turn into a horror game?
Oh, no, we're fine.
The Orange Islands.
This place is huge!
Yeah, they're...
Oh god, he's dead!
It is a horror game.
Need the bomb item for...
Wait, seriously?
Are you okay?
No, I'm not.
I'm dying!
This
is a very serious problem.
Oh, is there anything I can do?
All I wanted to do was ride the boat.
But no.
You're not allowed.
You have to wait until you're older.
Well, guess what?
I'm older now!
That was five minutes ago.
Hashtag, worst dad ever.
Hold on there.
I'll take you out later.
But later is a million years away!
Hey dad.
Hey Claire.
How's it going?
Um, I'm alright.
How's business?
Quiet.
At least I'm getting some good reading time in.
That's...
I guess that's a positive.
Yeah, this is my dad now.
Is the motorboat booked today?
Nope, not yet.
You want to take it for a spin?
The rental fee is a hundred coins!
No, I have a hat to buy.
Maybe later.
Talk to you later.
Where am I?
Oh, welcome to the Orange Islands.
Despite living in the shadow of Hawk Peak, this small cluster of islands has garnered a unique reputation of its own.
Are you able to guess how these islands got their name?
Uh...
It's the color of the rock.
It will probably surprise you, but the islands are named after the color of their rock!
Now that rocks!
That's a rock fact.
For centuries, travelers have been dazzled by the streams of red and orange that flow through these cliffs.
What gives these stones their vibrant colors, you ask?
Dead bodies.
Well, that's simply iron oxide you're seeing.
Now you know!
You've actually learned something new today.
I feel patronized somehow.
This game is so colorful.
What's this?
I got... Oh, is this for watering?
Uh, nope.
The Helianthus disultantis rubber flower.
Hawk Peak Provincial Park's official flower.
This unique species blooms instantly in flash flooding conditions, fading like a water balloon.
Maybe I have to put water in first.
Put water in it first.
You guys stop!
You guys stop reading my mind.
Please do not remove buckets from the pack.
A bucket full of water seems heavy.
I don't think I could fly or climb carrying a bucket full of water.
But I could probably still glide.
Okay.
Not... Oh, it's raining here too.
Spooky scary.
Oh, there's another one here.
Let's water this one.
Okay, alright, alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
Gone fishing.
This looks suspicious.
This looks mighty suspicious.
Once you successfully climb to the mountain, could you...
Maybe could you bring others up there?
Like some kind of...
Stop!
Do you think like...
Do you think she like that girl...
I don't know her name.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Do you think she like...
Has like a catchphrase...
Where she's like, talk to you later.
Do you think she's like...
Oh my god, I was about to do the same thing.
She's like...
Wow, I totally meant to do that.
She has a podcast called...
You're right!
I forgot about her podcast!
Yeah, that's right.
Let's see, where do we go from here?
This place is so big.
Maybe we go back...
To the...
To the trail.
We actually try to climb the mountain.
No, I'm not fishing anymore.
Sorry, every time I click out of the game, it stops the music.
I tried to get a doctor's appointment today.
This is the saddest thing, you guys.
I was trying to make the appointment.
Only to find out that...
I guess...
I don't have ghost insurance anymore.
So...
I have to figure that out.
I think I'll just go to...
I think I'll just go to one of the small clinics though.
To try and...
Oh, to get an appointment anyway.
So I can at least get some medicine.
Yeah, I don't know what happened.
Howdy.
I guess I'll just die.
I'm already dead!
Hi.
What you doing?
Taking a break?
Hey.
Don't tell anyone, alright?
I won't.
I don't even know who I'd tell.
Heh.
Good.
I can't wait to be done today.
When my shift's over, I'll be out catching me some rare fish.
It's my hobby, you see.
If you happen to net some fish yourself, bring them to me and I'll trade your coin.
I caught some fish already.
Oh?
Can I take a look at them?
Take a look at...
This way.
I don't...
This is my first fish that I sell.
Guess you'll have to double die.
Hold on now.
Oh.
What is this?
The rare albino nor...
It's rare?
That's a mighty catch right there.
80 coins.
Is that all?
Sell this tiny guy.
The brook trout, eh?
I'll give you 8 for it.
Oh, what?
Damn!
Our first catch was a catch!
That's all for now.
How did we get so lucky?
Lucky...
You can climb this thing?
Kind of.
This music is making me go a little bonkers.
What's that?
Something was shining over there.
I hope the plants...
I hope the plants stay...
Stay planted.
Or stay...
Bloomed.
Thank you so much!
We're so close.
We are so close to 15!
Then we'll know what that little punk was up to.
But if you take a trip to Europe and coincidentally need to visit the hospital, it's much cheaper.
No insurance needed.
We even have someone willing to host and take you on a tour.
Thank you for the suggestion, MissFist.
I'll be okay.
I just have to re-enroll.
But it was just kind of a shock when I was like, I need to make a doctor's appointment.
I hope I can get one today.
And then it was like, no, you don't get any at all!
I'm not going to go to a doctor just for a cold though.
Well, I mean a different country doctor.
Yo, this updraft is on point.
You could get some sick dives on it.
How do you dive?
Oh dang, it's easy!
But it takes some practice.
You gotta hear me out.
First, you gotta be gliding.
As you know, you glide by holding A.
Then if you're high enough off the ground, release your control stick and dive downward.
But you must still remember to hold A.
That's the tricky part.
With a good dive, you can build up a lot of speed.
You can practice by gliding over this updraft.
It'll give you a lot of height to work with.
I'm supposed to fly!
How do I empty it?
How do I empty the water bucket?
Scoop or pour?
I did press B.
I'm pouring.
Can I put it away?
And then let go.
I like the music there.
And then we go here, right?
And then we equip our bucket again.
And we pour.
Oh, it's empty.
I'm just gonna fly to the treasure chest.
I don't know if I get enough air though, is the issue.
Oh, yes I do.
I'm just stupid.
More money!
Seashell.
I imagine we'll get...
Wait, is this a pickaxe?
I was gonna say an actual axe, but I guess we don't need one.
The way forward is blocked.
Interesting.
Okay.
We're swimming.
We're collecting so much stuff.
Guys, we have just one more!
One more seashell.
Also, I saw whatever that was.
It looked like binoculars.
Okay, I think this leads back to the...
To the toucan, yeah.
Just one more!
Look, we can...binoculars.
Over here?
Over yonder?
Somewhere.
Hello?
Is it really high up or something?
I'm scared.
How far out can I swim?
To the trash.
This seems...dangerous.
This seems...
Does anyone have the...
The lessless phobia?
What is that ghost shadow then?
No!
I feel so bad!
Thank you, but no!
Thank you.
Get well soon threat.
Tomorrow I'm gonna go to a clinic and get some medicine.
Hopefully.
I don't think it'll be that much.
Whoever suggested the umbrella, thank you.
See, there's a shadow of what looks like binoculars here, but I can't tell where it's coming from.
Yeah, I'm so sick of being sick.
Maybe this way.
Over this way.
Maybe.
Pretty.
I have to climb him.
Actually.
I think I need more feathers.
Maybe this way?
No...oh wait.
Maybe possibly get a better immune system.
That's so true.
Why didn't I think of that?
I'm just gonna go buy a new body.
The final seashell!
We got it.
Oh, another stick.
Still don't know what these are for.
Back to Hawk Peak Island.
This bronchio thing is going around everywhere.
It's hard to shake off.
I'm on week two.
No!
Aw man.
Everybody's getting sick.
Stay healthy everybody!
Wait, did we just go in a circle?
I think we did.
We gotta go buy another golden feather.
I suppose.
Is it this way?
Where was that?
I think I'm lost.
I'm not lost.
I know exactly where I am.
What's this say?
Back to Hawk Peak Island.
Yeah, I get it.
Oh yeah, the hat too.
We gotta get our hat.
Awesome!
This fits us.
Oh my gosh, this is perfect.
This is absolutely perfect.
Hey kid!
I got your shells.
I'll take them.
And I get...
So now what?
Do I get anything?
No!
Not even a thank you?
That's not very nice.
I do what it takes to survive.
I never promised you anything.
Actually...
Oh, I do have something for you.
A new job.
I already have a job.
Well make this your side gig.
What if I don't take it?
It's your loss.
Good jobs are hard to find.
So what will it be?
But he's still not promising me anything.
I thought it was a fetch quest.
Okay, let's just do the side gig.
Good.
Take this.
Shell necklace.
And deliver it to Ranger Mei.
That is all.
Okay.
Hi Mentaichan.
Ranger Mei.
Was this Ranger Mei?
Who are you?
I've got a delivery.
It's from Jen.
Oh, wow!
It's so pretty.
She's such a sweet girl.
She kind of sucks.
Collecting all those shells must have been hard work.
Well actually...
Never mind.
Oh, I remembered something.
I found this golden feather in the cabin.
I figured you could use it.
Oh!
Worth, worth, worth, worth, worth!
This is weird timing.
Is this like a reward for delivering the necklace?
Uh, nope.
Oh, that was worth.
That was so worth.
So now...
Okay.
Now we have more stamina.
But we're going to go buy another one anyway.
We're going to buy so many...
golden feathers.
Oh wait, I never finished the rock climbing thing, did I?
I just left them hanging.
My bad.
Sorry, club.
I want to be like Godzilla through here.
Rock climbing club.
I guess I...
I got a golden feather.
Yep, great.
So to get started, you can try climbing the short wall here.
Just push against the wall and hold A.
Nice one.
Whatever.
The climb is easy.
Real pros use the big wall.
If you're having trouble with the big wall, just watch my technique.
It's highly refined from years of climbing.
Oh.
Dang it.
I want to show this guy who's boss.
I got this.
Wait.
Okay, hold on.
Wow, good climbing!
Eh, it was alright.
So, I know you can fly and all.
But your stamina will last longer if you climb places instead.
Push the kid, I know, right?
Cool.
What's next?
Come on.
Say the line.
To Hawk Peak.
Oh, okay.
I still need to warm up myself.
But I'll see you up there.
Alright.
I didn't realize you have stamina when flying too.
Curse game, curse game.
Hmm.
Oh, wait.
This is where I need to go, actually.
Buy a golden feather.
Now we have three.
And then we'll buy the sick hat.
Climb a wall.
The more golden feathers you have, the more you'll be able to climb and fly.
What kind of merch do you sell?
One hat.
I'll take it.
Provincial Park hat.
Why don't you try it on?
Can we?
Can we wear it?
Howdy.
You should be able to climb Hawk Tower.
What's Hawk Tower?
Oh.
What's up?
Wait, so I can buy another one.
It's actually all the feathers we have.
A boy came by earlier and bought most of our remaining stock.
You'll have to find more elsewhere.
Sorry.
Well, that's perfect, actually.
That works.
Perfectly for us.
We bought our hat.
We...
We bought our...
Our feathers.
We are living the life, baby.
Now we can do so much.
And explore so far.
I love explore.
I love to explore.
Nice.
Look at that.
What does it say?
Dear Sign Reader.
Hi.
I don't know you.
How would they even get a hawk...
to...
a...
island?
Wouldn't it be an island?
But you're probably pretty cool.
I'm cool too.
We should race each other.
It would be cool.
Very.
I'm gonna set up a ribbon at the lighthouse.
Avery.
Okay.
She sounds pretty.
I see something sparkly.
More seashell.
Oh, look at that.
More money.
So we're still looking for...
What?
The watch?
And...
Is there anything else?
And we gotta climb the mountain.
Oh, the headband.
We gotta go find that guy.
I figured I would still look around for the headband.
The actual one.
But I don't think it seems to be there.
No!
Okay, we can make this.
We can make this.
Probably.
Oh, I'm drowning?
A golden feather!
Okay, we wanna go to the Black Peak Trail.
We haven't been here either though.
Yeah, Blackwood.
That's what I meant.
Blackwood Trail.
So we go down...
And around...
And somewhere...
It said I was down.
Down, down, down.
By the river.
This way maybe?
They want me to climb.
Hawk Peak.
Good Creek Path.
Royal Bridge.
Okay, this is it.
Are those aliens?
What is that?
Can I zoom?
Sun.
I think we're having an invasion.
Look at that guy!
This feels like a jump scare.
It really does.
Why did it get so quiet?
It's freaking me out.
Okay, right over here.
Any luck finding my headband yet?
Well, I found this.
Does it smell like...
Boys?
Oh, boys.
Boys.
Boys smell.
That's not it.
The sweat stains aren't in the right place.
Ew.
Where did you find this?
Actually, the turtle gave it to me.
They said you could have it.
They're looking forward to the race and didn't want you to miss it.
What?
Really?
Taylor, the turtle?
They're like the regional champion?
This headband has to be at least twice as lucky.
Possibly even thrice.
Oh, quadruple lucky.
I underestimated its value.
Okay, I'll take it.
I'm so pumped.
Take these running shoes.
Yippee!
You can hold X to run with them.
However, just keep in mind that running requires golden feathers.
Oh, I missed this.
You guys almost had me just leave without taking my treasure.
We are speeding.
So now...
Let's go to the other side.
Where we were coming from before.
You think I can climb up this whole wall?
Holy moly!
Wow.
Our stamina is crazy.
Where are we?
You think we're on the trail?
The hawk peak?
I want to go look at the yellow area first.
Such progress.
I know, we're killing it.
Hello?
Take that.
Here.
It's so pretty.
What is this?
I found the secret.
The boxes can be moved.
Interesting.
Such a comfy game.
I'm feeling so snoozy.
Who's over here?
Anybody?
Abandoned?
Money hole!
And a stick.
Surely we'll need the sticks for something.
So it's good we're finding one.
Yeah, there was that boat ride too, right?
That we rejected earlier.
Dango!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
One moment.
Where's my bucket?
Oh, I got my bucket.
Okay.
This game makes me feel like there should be a mystery afoot though.
You know what I mean?
This
is it.
I'm grave robbing now.
Wait.
This is the mystery.
It has to be.
Why is there a cemetery here?
And the music is stopped.
Now it's raining.
The weather is a little finicky on this island I'd say.
My name is Avery!
It's a pleasure to meet you.
Hi, I'm Claire.
I think I saw your sign.
You did?
Excellent!
So have you come to race me?
Sure.
Fantastic!
So there's this abandoned building to the west of here.
At least, I think it's abandoned.
West.
Anyway.
I'm thinking we should race to the top of it.
Whoever touches the post up there first...
Oh, that's the one we saw before, right?
And also...
We should only use five golden feathers during this race.
I have five.
That'll make it more interesting.
You ready?
Awesome!
Let's do this!
Oh my god.
She's catching speed like crazy!
See ya Avery.
Where's the abandoned building?
Oh my god.
Avery?
I'm riding!
Shoot.
It's a tight race!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I have to admit, you are good.
But, I feel like I was just getting warmed up...
No.
Why not join the marathon?
There's this big race happening today.
Well, it's a little embarrassing but...
I was supposed to run in the marathon today.
But it turns out I missed registration.
Sorry, that sucks.
Yup, I gotta say, I was pretty bummed out.
Kinda felt like giving up on racing.
Then I spent like two hours watching parkour videos.
Now my new passion is parkour racing!
So whatever.
I'm glad you were willing to help me practice.
Uh...
That's it?
That's all we do?
Minecraft parkour?
You think Avery would jump for the beef?
Absolutely.
Avery would jump for the beef, 100%.
Wow, we don't get a reward?
Is it if we do a rematch?
Maybe.
You want a rematch?
Totally!
I'll do better this time.
Oh, where are we going?
Oh, it's the same thing.
I'm just gonna do the same thing I did before.
Uh, I think Avery's way ahead of me.
Wait, Avery, where are you?
Uh...
Wait, where the hell is the...
Where am I going?
I think I'm lost.
I think Avery is at the finish line.
Uh...
Where does it go?
Oh.
Birthday was on Jan 1st.
Any chance for a late happy birthday?
Love your video with Kiara.
Also, hope you feel better soon.
Thank you, Nervous J!
Sorry I missed your birthday.
Happy belated birthday!
Uh...
She is zoomed like crazy.
I got lost though.
I got kinda lost.
Yeah, look at you all smug up there.
I won!
You put up a good race.
That was really fun.
Oh!
I nearly forgot.
I've got something for you.
Oh, okay.
A walkie-talkie.
If you ever get lost during a race, ring me up and we can start over.
I did get lost.
How did you know?
Bye!
I think I'm good on the rematch.
Unless we actually get something.
I mean, we got a walkie-talkie, but...
She is too good.
A bit condescending, Avery.
I ducked here earlier.
I dug those up?
Really?
No, I did.
No way!
I did?
I didn't notice anything covering the ground!
That's a ghost.
Do you remember where you were buried and if you were carrying any valuables?
Just asking.
I don't remember.
I am...
Quite possibly the worst person ever.
Hey, Julie!
Hi!
How's the day going?
We're gonna play games all day!
Sounds fun.
Oh, so this is where we play...
Stickball.
Hey, looks like you got the net set up.
Are you two gonna play volleyball?
Volleyball?
Nah.
We invented our own game.
No way.
Stickball.
I think it's gonna be the next big thing.
Alright.
Clear!
I formally challenge you to a game of...
Beach Stickball!
That means you have to play.
Yeah!
You have to!
It's the law.
You can't fight the law.
Okay, okay.
I'll play.
Yay!
So, how do you play?
Step over to the other side of the court and I'll teach you everything to know.
Okay.
So, Beach Stickball has only three simple rules.
Rule number one.
Hit the ball with your stick.
Hit it real hard!
Rule number two.
Don't let it hit the ground.
I mean for the most part.
Julie is the ref so it's all up to her.
It's all up to me.
Rule number three.
Believe in yourself.
That's the most important rule.
Don't ever forget it.
That's pretty much it.
Are you ready?
I guess so.
Ready, set, go!
Oh gosh.
How do I hit?
Okay.
Nice.
Oops.
Did I lose?
Nope.
You can never lose.
Nine months is a wisp now.
It's an obvious joke.
I can't believe nine months.
Wow.
When you play Beach Stickball, everyone wins.
Except if you pop the ball.
Then I guess you lose.
Otherwise, Beach Stickball is a purely co-op game.
Oh, coop game.
You mean co-op game?
Yeah, a coop game.
It means we work together to get a high score.
That sounds nice.
We get a point for every pass we make.
If we can get it to ten points, I'll give you a prize.
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Oh, nice.
Eight.
Ten.
Shit.
Why did you shoot it over there?
Fourteen.
Yes.
We did it.
As promised, I've got a prize for you.
Nine months, please name the child.
Thank you.
Four.
You're really good.
With your skill, we might even be able to make it to twenty.
But that would still be pretty hard.
Do we get a prize if we get to twenty?
Oh.
Oh yeah.
Come on!
Stop hitting it so fast.
How do you count?
I hit seven.
The serve doesn't count.
Minky it is.
Minky!
Shine, bro.
Thank you for the rare.
Hello, hello.
What do you think, Claire?
It counts.
Fine.
You got seven points then.
Alright, let's do it again.
Let's get to twenty.
We're back!
Thanks for the gift.
Sorry.
I
have a depth perception issues.
Please, little guy.
Why are you there?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Eleven.
You never drop the ball.
Maryland makes it to five.
True.
Time to duel.
I thought this was a co-op game.
That implies no dueling.
What if I hit it the other way?
I don't know if I can.
Oh, it's a coop game.
Do we get anything?
If we get to twenty.
I wonder.
I want to know.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Thirteen.
What's your favorite coop game?
I don't have a favorite coop game, but I have a favorite cool game.
That's when you overthrow.
Mutiny!
Child support in eight.
A lot of minkys being born today.
Solid.
Okay, I'll try one more.
One more!
One more, one more.
Okay.
Nice.
Eleven.
Okay, nevermind.
I give up.
I don't care if we...
Oh, the ball is in here.
I can't even hit it.
I'm the worst.
My depth perception does not allow me to...
Continue further.
What is this?
Oh, the orange island.
Where is my bucket?
Ah, nice.
Oh, not nice.
Nice.
Okay.
We're back here in the spooky lands.
See, this one just looks like it's waiting to be dug up, you know?
Maybe it was fresh.
Fresh grave.
We're climbing up.
Oh, this is where we talked to Avery.
What do we see around here?
Oh, no, that's not what I meant to do.
We went there, didn't we?
I'm almost positive.
We went here and we dug something up.
Is this a horror game?
No, it's actually not.
Surprisingly.
Okay.
Don't get electrified.
Can you?
This game wouldn't kill us, would it?
Alright.
Time to climb.
It is time to climb the Hawk Trail.
Finally.
What's this?
Hawk Peak Trail.
Welcome back, Mito.
Hope you had a nice break.
Miss you so much.
Thanks, Daniel!
Thank you, thank you.
We're climbing.
This is it.
This is the moment.
This is what we've been training for.
What's this way?
Hawk Peak Trail.
This way.
This way?
Am I going the right way?
Yeah.
Okay, this way.
We're climbing.
We're finally doing it.
We're completing the game.
This is game completion music for real.
Oh, I'm drowning.
I'm gonna talk to this dog.
Heyo.
How's the hike treating you?
It's been nice.
It's really beautiful here.
I know, right?
The view from the top will be so good!
You're going to Hawk Peak too?
Oh, no.
That's too intense for me.
I'm just going to Outlook Point.
Will I see you there?
Yeah, I'll meet you at the top.
Awesome.
Catch you later.
Is that a stick?
No, I think that maybe it's just a shadow.
Oh, I'm drowning.
Oh, dog.
Hawk Peak.
I gotta go.
I'm faster than you.
Let me through.
Wait, which way do I go?
Outlook Point.
Okay.
Guys, I hope you're not afraid of heights.
Treasure.
Oh, a golden feather!
Nice.
I got seven now.
I remember Avery saying that she tied the ribbon around the...
I don't think we've been there yet.
The lighthouse.
Oh, wait.
No.
Didn't...
I was going to say, didn't I try climbing it?
Well, that's a big mountain.
Golden feather.
Down there.
Interesting.
Okay.
Wait, dog!
Dog!
Dog.
Heyo.
I was just up at Outlook Point.
I didn't see you there though.
Oops.
Oh.
But I was there!
Okay, let's wait for dog to come back.
I wish I could see what's inside here.
Stupid dog, I'm right here.
Literally at the point.
Stupid dog.
Idiot.
Dummy dog.
So my cats are better.
Breathe in that fresh air, guys.
I hope you don't have a stuffed nose like me.
Okay, golden feather.
Coins.
Oh, my goodness.
Okay.
What's wrong with my controller?
Why am I on turbo?
How do I turn it off?
Oh, my god.
I don't want to...
Oh, god.
I turned on turbo mode on.
I think on my controller I don't know how to turn it off.
Does anyone know?
Hold the turbo button.
The button that's turbo...
I didn't hold any other button, though.
Oh, gosh.
It's...
What is this?
I can't remember the name of it right now.
Hold on.
I have the 8-bit Dolan.
The 8-bit...
I knew that I had turbo, but I never use it.
Unplug.
It's not plugged in.
It's Bluetooth.
Maybe if I...
Maybe that.
Alright,
dog.
I'm here.
I'm at the sneaky point.
How long is this dog gonna take?
I wonder.
Oh, my God.
He's not even anywhere by us.
Dog?
Oh, my God!
He's still going down!
We'll come back.
We'll...
We'll come back for him.
I'm climbing.
I saw that treasure chest.
Huck Peak.
Meteor...
Oh, the Meteor Lake.
We haven't been there yet either.
Let's go up top first.
You can grab that golden feather first.
True.
We could attempt that.
Alright, dog's gotta be here now.
I'm running.
Dog!
Where was it though?
I just know it's this direction.
Doesn't seem very far.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, here we go.
Still trying to wait for him, but...
That
was so smooth.
Now I'm...
Oh, that's a turtle.
So now we're in the Blackwood area.
Nice flying, thank you.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
I meant to do this.
And we're going...
this way.
Run, run, run.
Run, you...
Oh, okay.
Dog is on his way back!
Let's just follow him.
I won't leave you behind this time.
This epic journey.
You and me, dog.
You and me.
Oh, I'm drowning, dog.
Oh, no.
I'm drowning, I'm drowning.
Okay.
Come on.
I'm a new bird.
I grew a new feather.
Raiders?
Oh, Julius.
Thanks for the raid.
Hello, hello.
Nice to meet ya.
This way.
We're trying to get this dog to the top.
Look, he's got not a single thought behind his eyes.
He's just a dog.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Come on, come on.
I said I'd meet you there, buddy.
I'm gonna meet you there.
Come here, come here.
Thanks for the gifted.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hey!
Good to see you up here.
Is it just me?
Or is this kind of epic?
Yay, thanks for the power of gifted.
Yeah, it's epic.
Yes!
The wind in my face.
It makes me feel so good.
Wind makes me feel good.
The visitor center is so tiny from here.
Oh, that reminds me.
Take this.
Wait, I forgot we got a treasure map before.
Apparently, there's some sort of treasure buried at Sid Beach.
I couldn't find anything.
Maybe I'll have better luck.
That's right!
We got two treasure maps now!
Oh my gosh.
So worth!
Let's go!
Okay.
Sid Beach.
Don't know where that is at all.
Let's just keep climbing for now.
There might be more.
I wonder if they're like, you gotta get all the feathers to get to the top though, buddy.
This looks a little ominous.
I think I stole someone's way back home.
Stick, stick.
Whoa, this guy's too cool.
Hey, king.
You wanna buy some golden feathers?
Yeah, okay.
Cool.
It'll be 100 coins per feather.
But, that's more than twice as much as the visitor center.
I thought the visitor center was...
100 also.
Scalper, yeah!
Yeah, drown in piss, scalper!
Oh, it's 40.
Go buy feathers from them then.
But, they're all sold out!
I guess you're out of luck.
Oh my god, so many raids today.
Ladies, saffron, thank you for the raid!
So, you're gonna buy my feathers or what?
This guy's a jerk.
Fine.
Alright then, pay up.
Nine feathers.
Smell ya later.
Don't do it.
I had to, I think.
At least seven golden feathers are required to complete...
Novice...
Look at this guy climbing.
Novice hikers should consider using more.
I'm no novice!
Maybe I shouldn't have bought it then.
I shouldn't have bought it.
I didn't need it.
Oh, it's our guy.
Oh, hey!
Seems like you've really gotten the hang of climbing.
Thank you for the gift.
Yeah!
I think I'm stuck!
It's too high!
What have I done?
I can't do this.
Take a deep breath.
Try and remain calm.
You're doing great.
And you know you can handle this.
This guy, this is karma.
What am I doing?
Just focus on the next step.
You've got this!
I've got this!
I hope you fall and break every bone in your body, buddy.
Let's travel this way.
Nice.
Okay, bye!
Thanks for the five gifts.
Nice.
Very good.
Our feathers are getting frozen!
That's not good.
Oh no!
Hello?
Heat.
Hold on there, young friend.
I hope you don't mind me saying, but you seem a little unpre- I do?
Unprepared!
It's mighty cold up here for folks who aren't accustomed.
I didn't expect it to get this cold!
My feathers are freezing up!
Hawk Peak is unique in the province for geothermal activity.
Oh, it was a hot spring.
I thought it was like the other one earlier where it was the gust of wind, you know?
If you get too chilly, stop at one of the hot springs.
That should give you back your strength.
You guys, do you think we're gonna make it?
What is this?
This looks like a place to dig.
Oh, wrong thing.
Shovel.
I think you can do it, streamer.
You think so?
You really think so?
You think we can get to Hawk Peak?
The top?
Oh, it's getting mighty, mighty breezy.
Hey,
it's you again.
We're almost at the top, but it looks like the bridge collapsed.
There might be another way up, or I could just go collect more golden feathers.
This is kind of epic here.
No, I'm so close!
I don't think I'll make it.
There's hot springs right there!
No!
Maybe let's go back to this one over here.
Maybe up here.
There was a hot springs up here.
I saw it.
Oh gosh!
No!
Are you kidding me?
So lame.
Oh, I just noticed the shiny over here.
Oh, and a treasure chest.
You guys, we still haven't found that guy's watch.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
Hot springs are hot.
Hot springs, hot springs.
I already lost a feather.
I don't know how.
Let's warm up.
Maybe I can climb in here.
Alright.
To up here.
I think I'm a little taller now.
Than before.
Let's try this way.
Don't use up a feather, don't use up a feather.
I think this goes to... I saw another collapsed bridge.
There's a fireplace here.
That's good.
What's in here?
Nothing?
OK.
Saladoa.
Welcome to Mambo Shop.
Thank you!
Oh no.
Oh yes, oh yes.
I feel like we are going down?
There's fish in that hot spring.
Let's fish a little.
We might get a rare guy.
Pre-cooked fish.
This is nice.
Mintos Mt.
Everest arc came so soon.
I want to climb Mt.
Everest.
White bass.
Can we fill our bucket here, I wonder?
We can.
And then... OK.
OK.
Hear me out.
Let's just equip this guy instead.
We go back to over here where I climbed up and there was a little...
Oh, I'm stuck.
There was a little plant we can...
We can water.
OK.
Oh.
Oops.
We
know this way is pretty much a bust.
Let's fly around.
Wait a second.
I think this is a... I think this is a shark guy.
Maybe.
Or is this...
OK.
Nice.
That works.
Don't waste feathers.
OK.
Try climbing.
I still don't have enough.
Maybe I do need to keep gathering feathers.
It says 7 minimum.
How the heck?
Just another dollar.
Maybe...
Wait a second.
Now we are here.
Wait.
OK.
Now if I do this.
Equip.
Fill.
Go down.
Water.
I guess this is a pretty good height.
What if I just go for it?
I did it!
Now he's gonna... No!
Don't sit down!
Don't fall asleep!
You'll die of hypothermia!
That's my streamer.
So peaceful.
The Aurora Borealis.
Is that it?
Is the world fading away or is it just me?
The reception!
Cellphone reception!
Hello?
Hi Claire.
Mom!
Is that the phone call we were waiting for?
Thank you for the 5k.
Thank you.
I'm so glad to hear from you.
I've been waiting all day to hear from you.
I've been worried.
Oh honey.
I told you I'd be fine.
But you always say that.
Why is it so annoying right now?
And I always am.
Anyway.
How have you been?
I'm at the top of Hawk Peak right now.
I love it up there.
Mei and I used to go up every summer together.
It's about time you made it up.
Yeah, I know.
You're so big now.
My little girl is leaving the nest.
Why is this so...
You won't have any need for little old mom.
But I do need you.
I'll never not need you.
When I heard about the surgery.
How come you never told me this was a thing?
I didn't want you to worry.
But I know you can get worked up about things.
I could have been there for you.
You're all alone there now.
Really, it was nothing.
Everything was fine.
Why is this so sad?
I'm just glad you're okay.
I love you mom.
I love you too.
Wait, something's happening.
Is that the famous Hawk Peak updraft?
Looks like it.
You should catch a ride on it now.
Before it fizzles out.
I wanna, but I'm kinda nervous.
Claire, you can do it.
I'll come visit you soon, okay?
Also, don't forget to say hi to Aunt May for me.
She's probably waiting for you back at the cottage.
Bye, love you.
Love you too mom.
Hawk Peak, you made it to the top.
What the heck?
I don't need my nose to be any more stuck.
Hold on, I want a fish in here.
The music got all exciting and I'm like, give me a fish.
Look, we sat down, so cute.
Probably get some good fish in here.
Big white bass.
Another one.
What if we catch a tuna?
Hawk tuna.
Another big white bass.
Hawk Peak, fly.
No, no, no, stop!
This is a wholesome game.
Okay, last try.
And jump.
Only white bass here.
I wanted to go this way maybe.
What about Meteor Lake?
We didn't get to go.
Oh, I'm freezing up.
I can't see anything.
We're too high up.
I don't know where we are at all.
Where's those graves I dug up?
Dive down?
We really start to, like, just nose dive when we do that.
A little scary.
Oh yeah, we've been here.
There we go.
I think we can go home from here.
Where was that boat?
I don't remember.
What's that?
Wait, what's this?
Hold on.
Oh wait, I did go through here, but it's blocked, isn't it?
Dang it.
I think it's like right over here.
I think.
I think it's like right...
Sand Castle.
Yeah, I was right.
Hey, did you make it to the top?
Yeah.
It was really nice.
Yeah, we'd have to find the exit, right?
I can see why you like it so much.
Though, it wasn't exactly a short hike.
I'm really tired.
Well, maybe that was a bit of an understatement.
Only a bit.
It's kind of been a busy day.
Oh yeah?
What have you been up to?
Well, I caught a really rare fish.
Since when did you learn to fish?
Just today.
Wow.
You have been busy.
That's all I did.
All I did was catch a rare fish.
Also, I played a game of beach stickball.
What's beach stickball?
It's some game the kids play.
They're always playing something new.
You can't keep up with the youth these days.
Oh, I won a parkour race today.
Yeah, I did.
Wow.
What's parkour?
It's like jumping around and climbing stuff.
That sounds fun.
Anywho.
You hungry?
I'm gonna break out the hotdog soon.
Well, I'm kind of tired out.
I'm gonna go take a nap or something.
Alrighty then.
Have a good one.
I think it'd be nice to take a break.
The end.
Did we get the hotdog?
Thanks for all the hotdogs!
No hotdog, bad end.
This song kind of reminds me of Over the Garden Wall.
Loveliest?
Luckiest?
I don't remember the words, sorry.
Oh, the end.
Take a nice long nap.
And I guess that's it.
Well, hold on.
Let me see.
I feel I didn't...
Okay.
There's quite a few...
Achievements I didn't get.
Oh, so collect 10 feathers.
10 golden feathers is an achievement.
Parkour master.
Beat each parkour race once.
Feathers forever.
Water find every feather.
Trade every species of fish from the journal.
Complete the boating challenge.
Oh, we didn't even do the boat.
Water every sprout.
And then there's four hidden achievements.
That's a short game.
Well, it was a short hike.
Yeah, we didn't do the boat.
I think that's okay though.
This was so cute.
One down, 49 to go.
Congrats on beating your first game of 2035.
Yeah, you're so right.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
100%'ing this takes a bit longer.
It's still a short game.
How many fish are there?
Usually in these types of games, I feel like there's...
Hundreds of fish, you know?
I don't mind today as being a little bit shorter of a stream though.
Because I...
Do kind of need to rest up.
And I have an event.
In just a few hours.
Actually.
That was a cozy stream.
Thanks, Mindy.
Mindy.
This was the web fishing guy too, right?
Was it?
I don't know.
I think...
Wasn't this the pumpkin game?
Yeah, I was thinking that too.
I was thinking that too, the pumpkin game.
The one that we did...
The pumpkin festival.
No, wait.
That was different.
It showed a fox.
Not a...
Not a bird.
I don't know.
I'm gonna see.
Hold on.
A...
Short hike.
Dev.
No.
Oh, what is this?
Is this...
Is this the only game?
Hold on, I'm gonna look on Steam instead.
Store page.
Oh, here's a couple.
A tiny hike.
And pitfall planet.
It looks like a platformer.
This one was so cute.
The cozy stream bundle.
Cozy.
If you like this, you should check Celeste.
I think...
Celeste is...
Not cozy.
I think Celeste...
I think...
I think maybe you see mountain and you're like...
Yeah, Celeste.
I think it's a little bit different.
Maybe.
Just become a platforming god and it will be super chill.
True.
One screen took me over 500 tries.
I think I'd have to be in a complete Zen mode.
To...
To attempt Celeste.
I would have to be like...
Today...
I will not rage.
We are Zen.
Today we are...
Free of all...
Of all rages.
Which is like...
Never for me.
Zen gaming.
Cozy depends on the individual.
Hollow Knight is my cozy game.
I mean, yes, that is very true.
Hollow Knight.
I don't know what my cozy game is.
Minecraft?
Hollow Cure?
I don't know.
Picross.
Bloons?
Bloons.
I love Bloons.
The collectors of this came with a fold-out map visitor...
Guys.
Hold on.
The treasure map!
I must do first.
It says...
Upon a stormy cliff top, one should pause to see the view.
Peer through the earthy window, gold is hidden in the blue.
Sounds like a gold feather.
Okay.
And then I can get that achievement.
For ten gold feathers.
And then I'll feel satisfied.
I think.
I can see my house from here.
Yes, Claire?
It's me!
Can you hear me up here?
Sure can.
Okay.
This game is so cute.
Is there something at the top of the...
There is.
Wait, how do I get through here?
Maybe we have to climb...
Wait, but I don't have...
Okay.
We'll have to...
We'll have to fly.
I don't have a bucket.
Meteor Lake Outlook.
Oh, this is the Meteor Lake.
We did go here.
I just didn't realize.
I see, I see.
Okay, treasure, treasure, treasure, treasure.
Oh, take the water.
How do I get back up there?
Can I get back up there?
Bush circle looking sus.
Where did you see that?
Oh, this one.
You're right.
You're so right.
I bet there's coins in here.
I was right.
Uh...
They're here?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
I got the achievement.
We should still do the treasure map though, right?
That's awkward.
It was like over here, right?
No, this is where that guy is chilling.
Kind of over here.
So that just happened.
Awkward turtle.
Maybe I can fly from here.
Or climb, I mean.
This doesn't look very spooky at all.
Where's the spooky?
Okay, let's fly from here.
We're gliding.
Oh, who's that?
Oh, wait.
Okay, hold on, hold on.
So we're here, we're here, we're here.
What was the hint?
It says...
Upon a stormy clifftop, one should pause to see the view.
Peer through the earthy window, gold is hidden in the blue.
That window?
That one?
Earthy window.
This looks like an earthy window.
I don't think it's the ruins.
But there was a treasure chest over there.
Gold is hidden in the blue.
On top of the arch?
That?
Sorry.
Stop!
Stop, please!
Oh, I found it.
I can't see anything.
Is this the arch?
I don't think so.
Oh, the arch is over here.
Arch is here.
Okay.
Dig in the water?
Syntax!
It's your birthday.
I'm happy because you're here.
In fact, it's my birthday.
As precious as...
Happy birthday...
to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear syntax error.
Happy birthday.
Guys, I don't know.
I'm getting bested by this children's game.
I don't know.
Oh, that's right.
This is the bloom.
Dig on the beach.
I think that's it.
Possibly.
I guess so.
Sid beach.
I hid my treasure from the world, but never far from reach.
You will find it in one piece.
It rests between the mossy stones that lie upon Sid beach.
What is Sid beach?
Try fishing.
With...
Big common carp.
I'm just gonna guess that this is the treasure.
Because we dug it up, you know?
I'm gonna guess that that's the treasure.
Like I said, we got this one.
It's just out in the open.
What the heck is Sid beach?
Do we have a map?
Like sometimes when I fall, Claire's face is just like...
Maybe the real treasure was the friends we made along the way.
Must be.
Oh, this is the place where we can rent a boat.
Let's try it out.
Can I rent a boat?
Thank you.
Here's the key.
Oh, and you read the provincial motorboating safety and operations guide, eh?
Yeah, great.
Have a good time out there.
I have.
Maybe we can find the beach with this.
I didn't lie.
I probably knew it.
Oh my god!
Sid beach, here we come!
Sorry.
We never found the watch and that bugs me so much.
If I were a watch, where would I be?
Is this Sid beach?
This is mossy.
Do you think this is Sid beach?
Anything behind the waterfall?
I don't know.
These look mossy stones, right?
Can't tell.
Hold on.
I don't see Sid anywhere.
I don't know if that guy... that guy's probably dead.
Sid died.
I killed him.
I need like a little... what's the word?
Like a... one of... these, these, this, this.
Sid beach is this way!
Sid beach is this way.
I'll teach you to mess with me, Sid.
This looks suspicious.
Nevermind.
What do you mean it's the wrong way?
It's this way.
Who is this?
What is this?
Who are you?
What are you painting?
Oh, you can't tell.
It's supposed to be the coastline.
Though, I'm trying to go for a more abstract look.
I think I can see it now.
Still a work in progress.
I don't know if I like where it's going.
I think I'm gonna head over to the Blackwood Forest lighthouse soon.
I'm still trying to find the right inspiration.
I also think I see...
a...
Oh damn.
No, I thought I saw a...
What's it called?
A little digging spot.
Chest top left?
Yeah, the one I just got, right?
Is this Sid beach?
Wait, mossy blocks.
I think it's here.
I think it's here, I think it's here.
Here, here, here.
No.
This is mossy rocks, right?
Nice drift, thank you.
I'm a professional.
I don't know.
It's just some bushes.
No.
Those rocks are swaying...
They could be soft.
From the water.
And the cold.
Mossy rocks.
That's a mossy rock.
I don't know, I give up.
I don't know, I need a walkthrough.
Game facts.
I need a gamer facts right now.
Maybe further down, you think so?
Let's see.
What's that?
I think that says to the main island.
What's this area?
I'm okay.
Oh, I'm causing erosion?
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
It's like those people that go to the beach and like, dig.
Like, they connect the rivers to the beach and like, just mess up the ecosystem entirely.
So my sources say you've delivered the goods.
Your sources are correct.
So what about that pay?
Okay, okay, here you go.
Enjoy your shell.
Wait, did he give me the shells back?
This punk ass kid.
At least we can get around so fast now.
I think Sid Beach is a myth.
I don't think it exists.
Auntie, don't look!
Don't look, Auntie!
It's a myth!
It's a lie!
The beach is a lie!
I think I'm steering pretty well, I'm not gonna lie.
Like, these are bushes.
Those aren't rocks.
The music is so loud.
I think that was a mossy beach.
It said mossy rocks though, right?
Or am I crazy?
Mossy stones.
I haven't seen a single mossy stone!
Oh, that looks suspicious right there though.
Hold on, first let's do this.
Oh, no, uh...
This?
No, uh...
Nevermind.
Suspicious?
More coin.
Did you want a hint?
Yes, please!
Yes, hint please.
Please help.
Help, please.
Help, onegaishimasu.
No hint.
Yes, hint!
Are you saying I have no intelligence?
This is secretly a horror game.
I can get this one too.
Mint intelligence.
I keep doing that on accident.
I don't need your stinking money.
I'm trying to find a dang...
Watch.
Go back to the climbing wall is the hint.
Mossy rocks!
Yippee!
I think we solved both treasure maps then.
And, uh...
I think I already found this one.
Okay, nice.
So it does tell you.
So we did it.
So that was it.
Good, good, good.
Uh...
More maps somewhere, I think.
Probably.
But we got our...
We got our ten...
Ten feathers.
Did you check the other map?
Oh, I can check it.
Pretty sure this is it though.
I'm on like 99% positive.
Yep.
Pirate!
Five.
Can you say a seashore seller sells seashells?
Yep.
That one doesn't trick me up.
Sally sells seashells by the seashore?
That one doesn't trick me up very much.
Sally sells seashells by the seashore.
It's all about those...
I...
Oh, someone said about behind the waterfall.
Let's go check that and then I'll close out.
Irish...
Wristwatch.
Irish wristwatch.
I don't think there is anything behind here.
I'm climbing the water fountain.
I mean waterfall.
It's not a water fountain.
I mean this could be a water fountain.
A really big one.
Another stick.
We never found out what we need the stick for.
It is a mystery.
Left unsolved.
Unsolved mystery.
Mystery.
We could probably climb the mountain again.
Irish wrist...
Oh, wishy-washy.
Yeah.
Oh, that dog.
I'm gonna climb the mountain.
Oh, wrong way.
I'm a new bird.
I've climbed.
I've climbed and I will climb again.
Oh, there is a treasure chest down there.
Watch!
No!
How the hell am I supposed to find this watch?
I think...
It's fake too.
I think the sticks are related to the boat.
Perhaps.
Perchance.
What is over... Did I go over here?
Before?
Maybe not.
Sorry, I like just kind of exploring in this game.
Even though I've basically gotten everything, but it's still kind of fun.
Well, not everything, you know.
Rubber flower.
Oh, so you can get it here too.
Cool.
You can get the flower here too.
Oh, now we have two buckets.
Okay, let's go.
Okay.
What if I climb this?
You think we'll make it?
I don't think we're gonna make it.
So close.
Oi, oi, oi.
Am I frozen?
Will we make it?
Nope.
Sad.
Sad times.
Sad times for our little bird friend.
Okay, alright, alright.
One more climb, everybody.
One more climb.
The final climb.
Oh, they're here.
Hey you guys, how's it going?
Oh, you know, pretty good.
I just conquered Hawk Peak.
Like, no big deal.
Nice.
You made it to the top too?
Wow, almost conquered it.
We're basically there, right?
Well, technically, this whole area is considered Hawk Peak.
See?
Nailed it!
We're gonna make it to Hawk Peak's peak another day.
I think we're at our limit.
It's better not to push yourself too hard, right?
Definitely.
Safety always comes first.
You made it up though.
How was it?
It was beautiful.
The northern lights are really bright up there.
I can't wait to see it myself.
Aww.
Yeah, give up, dummy.
Suspicious rock formation.
The music here is so dramatic.
It makes me nervous.
Wait, I've done the suspicious rock formation.
Yes, I have.
Is this where we did it before?
Pretty sure.
Yeah, this is the strat.
Look into a room.
It only relieves nasal congestion for a few hours, but it's really effective.
I see.
Thank you.
I think I need actual med meds though.
I appreciate it.
I've been taking medicine, but I think I need an antibiotic or something.
God, this is so easy.
Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
That's not what I wanted to do.
I want to climb.
There we go.
Yeah!
The air in the mountain of the Hawk Peak is quite refreshing.
That's a neat bird.
Did you know that my name in Welsh means little raven and crow?
Your parents like birds?
Nice Tia impression.
Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
Thanks for the stream, Mintow.
Thank you guys!
This is such a cute little game.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Just a sweet little short hike.
I know it's a little stressful sometimes.
Uh...
Oh, Tia is here.
Gotta go!
Thank
you guys for the stream.
Otsumito!
And I'll see you guys later!
If you are at any party tonight, I'll see you there.
If not, then I'll see you next stream.
Or next event.
Or next whatever.
Bye-bye!
Otsumito!